Speaker 1: Well, my friends, it is happening
again. A lawyer for former Vice President Mike
Pence recently discovered a dozen classified
documents at Mike Pence's Indiana home. These
documents have now been turned over to the FBI
for review. Now, at this early stage in this new
investigation related to classified documents,
it's not completely clear what documents were
found at Mike Pence's house, their level of
sensitivity or other details. But let's remember
that multiple times, former Vice President Mike
Pence stated There are no classified documents in
my possession. There are no classified documents
at my house. Now, let's think about this just for
a moment, because this is becoming a much bigger
story than any particular classified document,
although we will get to the aspect of this story
that relates to classification. That's a separate
story. It's a relevant one, but it's a separate
story. Think for a moment the same Republicans
who were furiously apoplectic lee up in arms about
the supposed mishandling of classified documents
at Joe Biden's private office. And residents are
now conveniently silent about the discovery of
classified documents at the home of another
one of their own. Because remember, the same
thing happened with Donald Trump with hundreds
of documents which he tried to keep and wanted at
his house. Orders of magnitude difference between
these stories. But you one could argue you put the
Trump situation aside, that the Biden and Pence
situations are much more analogous or similar.
I want to remind you of some things that former
Vice President Mike Pence previously said. Here
is an interview that Mike Pence gave to ABC News
back in November and this exact topic came up.
Speaker 2: You take any classified documents
with you from the White House? I did not.
Speaker 1: Know.
Speaker 2: Do you
see any reason for anyone to take classified
documents with them leaving the White House? Well,
there'd be no reason to have classified documents,
particularly if they were in an unprotected area.
Speaker 1: Right now, is his answer technically
correct in that someone else took them assistance,
took them whatever. You know, we start to
get into this more semantic discussion of
what does it really mean to take, what does
it really mean to have, what does it really
mean to relocate a document? But of course, the
spirit of this conversation is that there are no
such documents at his house. Here's another
example of Mike Pence. This was from earlier
this month, in fact. Take a listen to this one.
Speaker 2: Our staff reviewed all of the materials
in our office and in our residence to ensure
that there were no classified materials,
that that left the White House or remained in
our possession. And I, I remain confident that
that was done in a thorough and careful way.
Speaker 1: I guess it wasn't right. I guess I
guess he was wrong about that as well, and has
completely lost control of what's going on in
his home. I mean, there were funhouse mirrors
and you couldn't tell that the documents were
classified. Who the hell knows? But obviously
not true. Let's look at one more instance of
this. Here is Mike Pence in a previous interview
saying he doesn't want to diminish the importance
of protecting classified documents and that
everything was very buttoned up. Every I was
crossed and t dotted. I know. I know. It's
a it's a HANNITY thing. Here is Mike Pence.
Speaker 2: Never want to diminish the
importance of protecting classified
documents and aberrations secret and never.
There was a very formal process during my time.
Speaker 1: It was super formal.
Everybody wore tuxedos while they did it.
Speaker 2: At the White House to see to that.
Speaker 1: Yeah no it I'll have oh, by the way,
he had documents at his house despite claiming
multiple times that he didn't. So my biggest
asset, my biggest issue with this story is the
astounding hypocrisy that is that has come to
light and has become I mean, unabashedly. They
don't even blush when they present their double
standards. And it goes to show that the Republican
Party will play politics with national security
if we believe that they consider this
issue of classified documents to be a
matter of national security, they claim it is,
at least when it's Joe Biden, if we believe that.
And yet they still use these situations to attack
the opposing party but never themselves, it means
they are turning a blind eye to the very national
security issue that they claim these national
these classified documents situations represent,
which means there is nothing they will not play
politics with. And that's absolutely the case.
Now, there's another issue. Okay. I read online
people saying, well, you were at this point, you
should really check every former president's house
and office and every former vice president's house
and office, apparently because of what's going on.
I proposed to you that this is not limited to
presidents and vice presidents. It would be a
shock to me if they were to search the offices
and residences of cabinet members, for example,
maybe not secretary of the interior, but certainly
like secretary of state is an example. I would be
shocked if there weren't some classified documents
at the homes of others as well. Democrats,
Republicans. Notice I'm not mentioning partizan
politics here. Is it ridiculous or is it to be
expected? I don't know. You know, the truth is
that elected officials review thousands or tens of
thousands of files when they're in office. Things
get moved around, Things could get misfiled,
misclassified, misplaced, whatever. It's not a
defense, by the way, because I believe every one
of these cases should be investigated. And I'll
get to that in a moment. But when you are dealing
with this volume of documents and you're dealing
with human beings, after all, it's not a huge
shock. What it shouldn't be is a partizan issue.
If it is determined that files have been found
and it genuinely seems that it was an accident,
an oversight, whatever, they should be returned
immediately. Law enforcement should look into
it. And then we have to move on and go beyond
that. Now, as I said before, the DOJ should treat
every one of these situations the same in that
they should investigate all of them. If and when
the investigation reveals that the facts of each
situation is different, then you start dealing
with the situations differently. And so if you
look at the Pence and Biden situations, which
I do believe are quite similar and you find
this was not intentional, these documents
were found and immediately turned over,
etc., etc.. And then you look at the Trump
situation and you're talking about hundreds,
not a dozen documents. You're talking about
people on video moving them or moving these
documents around when Trump has already been asked
to return them. You look at Trump using lawyers to
try not to return them, and then the lawyers
lie and say, we've turned over everything we
have. But then it turns out they didn't. That
is a different set of facts. And so that would
change the scope and nature of the investigation
now. Mitch McConnell was asked about this and he
sort of played coy. Take a look at what he said.
Speaker 3: What is your level of concern about
classified records showing up in Joe Biden's
home and now Mike Pence? And what specifically
should Congress do to prevent this from
happening? Well, there's record of how the
Justice Department handles it. I think they ought
to treat. Everybody's the same. Who has misplaced
classified documents?
Speaker 1: Now, that is
an interesting statement because it does
appear that Joe Biden misplaced documents.
From what we know at this point, it seems
as though Mike Pence misplaced documents.
But Trump stole documents. Trump gathered up had
gathered up hundreds of documents and had them
sent to his house. That's very different than
a dozen documents were left over and they were
found and immediately returned. So in a sense, you
know the spirit of what Mitch McConnell is saying.
Sure. Yeah. I mean, treat all of these things the
same in that they should all be investigated. But
misplaced is a mischaracterization of much
of what we believe took place here. Now,
I want to bring up a separate but valid issue.
Is there overclassification of documents in the
United States? You know, I'm not going to be able
to answer this question for you in order to really
answer this question accurately. One needs to have
access to documents I simply don't have access to,
and one needs to have insight into the exact
process for classification that I certainly don't
have. But we've talked about overcriminalization
in society as a problem. And separately, there
are people who have access to this apparatus
of classification who say that in the United
States we habitually over classified documents and
that arguably some of these documents could be the
Biden documents, the Pence documents, the Trump
documents, whatever some of these documents maybe
really shouldn't even have been classified in the
first place. A difficult question for me or many
of you in the audience to answer, but certainly
a valid question that can and should be asked